國威 有你的信
蛤 什麼
我看看
蛤 這是帳單欸
這電費也太貴了吧
哇 辦公室攝影棚這麼大
真的好耗電
上一集 我們聊到建築耗電的最大宗
空調 要怎麼省電
接下來 我們要來處理這個
就是關不掉 一直吃電的 燈
你看 白天有太陽照進來
開燈很浪費
但不開燈 感覺又太暗
我們需要的 其實是能依照天氣
隨時控制 LED 亮度的開關
然而人眼的瞳孔
會因為環境光線變化而自動縮放
適應亮度
因此很難精準地感受到光線細微變化
真正能幫上忙的是
日光感測調光控制系統
這套系統包含光感測器與調光控制器
並且有兩種運作方式
第一種是把感測器裝在窗邊
當窗邊自然光增強
感測器偵測到總照度上升
控制器便會計算誤差值
叫 LED 降低輸出功率
第二種方式
則是把感測器裝在遠離窗邊的室內
外面的光有多少都不管
直接量房間內的亮度
只要覺得暗了 燈泡就調亮一點
太亮了就調暗一點
因為台灣日照充足 這種技術
能減少 20% 至 60% 的照明用電
辦公大樓的照明能耗
約佔總體的 15% 至 20%
內政部建研所訂出的建築能效標示 BERS
採用 照明功率密度 LPD
作為評估核心
那要降低這個 LPD 且不犧牲視覺舒適度
就需要這種晝光利用技術
例如台達電的總部大樓
透過整合高光效 LED 燈具
與全數位控制系統
照明系統減少了 60% 的用電量
蛤 你覺得這樣節能還不夠多
非常好
因為接下來 我還有四種更厲害的方法
一定有一種方法
可以拯救你我的帳單
省電的第一個關鍵 仍然是太陽
想省冷氣電費
買台好冷氣並不是唯一解
建築外殼是能量交換的第一道防線
你也知道 有窗戶和沒窗戶的房間
溫差有多少
但就算你把窗簾全部都拉起來了
陽光還是會照在建築物的外牆
緩緩的幫外牆水泥加熱
最後連你家都一起熱
這也是大家都不想住頂加的原因
所以關鍵不在室內窗簾 而是 外遮陽
打從一開始 我們就要在熱進入室內前
把它阻擋在窗外
是這樣的
你可能看過不少建築前面
有像這樣的格柵結構
許多不只是為了外觀好看 而是為了遮陽
遮陽板當然不是隨便釘一塊板子就好
它完全就是幾何學的計算結果
遮陽板分為水平和垂直兩種
有沒有裝對差很多
而這又與你家或你公司的面向有關
如果你的家或公司窗戶面南
就要使用水平遮陽
這是因為台灣夏季太陽高度角很高
水平遮陽能像帽簷一樣
能有效阻擋來自上方的高角度陽光
如果窗戶朝東或朝西
光線就會從側面射入
水平板子當然擋不到
不管你用的是遮陽板或是百葉窗
記得都要選擇垂直的
說到這裡 我們都有共識
省電不代表要少開冷氣或是不開燈
而是要用科技的方法 被動省電
雖然看似都只省下一到兩成
但積少成多嘛
電費帳單的數字就是這樣慢慢省出來的
可是 我們也都想知道
到底有沒有 最有效 的節能方式呢
有一個辦法可以找到
沒錯 就是我剛才提過的
由內政部建研所推出的這一套
建築能效評估系統 BERS
BERS 系統撇開了 使用者的隨機行為
例如電腦 吹風機 跑步機
這種使用習慣差異大的行為
聚焦在 建築本體的物理性能
也就是建築物維持運作所必須的
維生系統
這包含 外殼 空調 照明 電梯 以及熱水
只要控制好這五大關鍵次系統
就等於控制了整棟建築
約 75% 以上的能源消耗
BERS 訂出明確的耗電密度指標得分
簡單來說 就是每平方公尺的面積上
每年平均的用電量
好
剛才我們解決了照明和外殼
接下來要來處理一個很多人都忽略的地方
熱水
在宿舍 醫院或旅館
熱水可是頭巨大的耗能怪獸
那為了省電 你覺得該挑哪一種熱水器呢
瞬熱型 還是儲熱式 都不是
而是 熱泵
一般加熱棒每消耗一度電
大概能產生 0.9 度左右的熱
熱泵 呢 一度電
大概能生出 3 到 4 度的熱
等等 這違反能量守恆定律了吧
其實也沒有 因為熱泵不直接產生熱
而是 搬運 熱
它翻轉冷氣的原理
冷媒在蒸發器中吸收環境空氣的熱量
壓縮機壓縮提高溫度與壓力
最後在冷凝器釋放熱量給水
因為加熱水的能量來自環境
消耗的電能只用在驅動壓縮機搬運熱量
而非直接轉化為熱量
所以性能係數 COP
也就是提供的能量除以消耗的能量
這個值會高於 1
補充說明一下
冷氣 冰箱這種用到熱泵原理的
COP 通常也都高於 1
要節能 換熱泵就對了
熱水也解決了
下一個省電重點不在你的房子內
而在公設中 那就是電梯
你可能不知道 台灣曾有全世界最快的電梯
台北 101 的觀景台電梯
極速是每分鐘上升 1010 公尺
相當時速 60 公里
2004 年拿下 全世界最快速電梯 的
金氏世界紀錄認證
但 物理定律無法迴避
快的代價就是超耗電
要把物體抬升 就要增加位能
需要投入的功 相當於質量乘以高度
再乘以重力常數 g
為了不要拉的那麼辛苦
電梯內部一定設有滑輪組
一邊是乘客搭乘的車廂
另外一側是掛鐵塊的配重
配重的重量一般介於空車廂與滿車廂之間
當滿載客人的車廂要上樓
因為車廂在下而且重量大於配重
電梯的馬達 也就是捲揚機需要出力運轉
把車廂往上拉
但下樓就不一樣了
滿載的車廂本來就會往下掉
這時捲揚機會進入發電機模式
下落的位能
會轉成發電機內的電能而不是動能
因此能減緩掉落的速度
那這些電該怎麼辦呢
因為這些回生電流時有時無
又是直流電而非交流電
其實難以進到電力系統中
我們一直以來的做法都很直接
就是加裝一個 煞車電阻
把這些電能轉成熱能消耗掉
但現在想想 這真的太浪費了
要知道在高層建築物中
電梯與自動扶梯
佔建築總能耗的 5% 至 10%
這些電 都平白被浪費掉了
也因此 現代建築
例如台電大樓和國立海洋科技博物館
都安裝有電梯能源回收系統
捲揚機回生的電力會先進入變頻整流器
成為大樓的電力規格
再回送至大樓電力系統內
提供給電網的其他設備
例如照明或空調使用
光是這個小改動
就能節省 15% 至 20% 的運行電力
終於來到最後一招
要達到 BERS 的 1+ 級 近零碳標準
除了節流 還需開源
在都市叢林中
最好的方法就是鋪設太陽能板
但屋頂面積有限啊
屋頂沒空間 但外牆不是有嗎
隨著高樓遍地林立 一棟比一棟高
外牆的表面積也不斷增加
這 就是立面光電
雖然我們都知道
立面光電設立在垂直的外牆上
單位面積能接收到的日照量確實低於屋頂
但它很大啊 面積超大這優點 不容忽視
還有 它不只能發電
還能當作遮陽的外牆阻擋熱輻射進入室內
降低空調負荷 既開源又節流
在這塊做的最有創意的
是臺南市政府民治市政中心目前所在的大樓
這棟建築改裝立面光電已經快 20 年了
當時
建築南面直射太陽的部分沒有任何遮陽
只在內部窗簾安裝隔熱
因此改裝外牆的另一目標 就是隔熱
結果怎麼樣呢
你看 整個立面光電結構像個玻璃盒子
確保採光
太陽能板不是直接黏在牆面
而是在牆面上的格柵結構內
安裝 345 片略有傾斜的光電板
既確保發電量
從正面看也幾乎看不到太陽能板
維持窗戶視野的通透性
更有趣的是 整個玻璃艙結構上下都有開口
當太陽直射時內部空氣被加熱
空氣膨脹往上
會產生煙囪效應帶動氣流
被動地讓自然空氣流動於建築外牆
帶走熱量
對了 幫建築裝煙囪 可以點這裡來複習
從外殼 空調 照明 電梯 以及熱水
雖然每項看起來都只減了一點點
但當我們每項都實實在在做到了 打勾
離我們建築完全淨零的目標也不遠了
電費也可以很有感地省下來了
你覺得還有哪種方式能不用犧牲生活品質
同時又能讓我們
電費帳單上的數字少一點
留言告訴我們吧
你可以先點這裡看看
為什麼裝根煙囪就能省電
也可以點這裡 瞭解建築施工時怎麼節能
記得訂閱 PanSci 泛科學頻道 開啟小鈴鐺
加入頻道會員
鎖定更多精彩的科學新知 科學議題
我們下次再見